the future being assembled piece by
piece at unlv a human-like robot
developed by engineer students
attracting worldwide attention in fact
the team just advanced in a global
competition and was selected as one of
15 across the world to compete next fall
10 million dollars on the line but the
technology being created right here is
priceless
meet avatar hubo standing five feet five
inches tall weighing in at 175 pounds
this robot looks every bit the part of a
hollywood movie but here inside the
robotics lab at unlv the real stars are
the ones who've dedicated gears to this
groundbreaking technology so many late
nights in this lab so many days so many
weekends there's always improvements dr
gene chagus vass is the team captain and
lead engineer my ultimate goal is to
have let's say a firefighter that can
embody the robot and perform the same
job but at a safe location it's all
possible with this special haptic suit
i'm able to feel whatever
touch is applied to the robot be that a
light touch or something with force it
varies with the amount of pressure that
you decide to put onto the robot and the
special virtual reality headset allows
the wearer to see what hubo sees because
it uses two cameras it
creates stereographic vision much like
our eyes work that helps with depth
perception which allows for more
lifelike movement it's just tracking the
motion of the arm and then sending that
data over to the actual arm of the robot
there's no joystick there are no cables
avatar hubo is unlimited in its movement
dr chagas vas says the implications for
this kind of technology are endless as
for the immediate future his team will
focus on developing hubos fine motor
skills manipulate and move at the same
time that's a very complicated task for
robot even though you can hug and high
five hubo and share emotion through the
avatar screen
don't worry robots aren't taking over
the world
yet no we're not trying to make the
robots conquer the world but rather
we're trying to you know improve the way
of life
the team says one of the things that
they're going to accomplish for the
global competition is walking and
holding hands with avatar hubo